[موسيقى]
القصف المبكر هو حالي شائعه جدا عند
الشباب والرجال اذا
يعنى فيها تقريبا واحد على اربعه واحد على
خمسه من كل الرجال شو هي هي وقت بصير
الرجل بيحصل على النشوه بفتره لا تتعدى
ثلاثه دقائق
تكون قليله جدا لدرجه انه يحصل على النشوي
باقل من دقيقه لاسباب القذف المبكر عده
فرضيات منا بتقول انه في فرق من الاحساس
على مستوى العضو الذكري ومنها بتقول انه
في ضعف بتقلص عضلات الحوت من شان هيك بصير
في عدم السيطره على القذف بس الفرضيه الي
هي مثبت اكثر انه هذا الموضوع ياتي من
الراس الموضوع هو كنايه عن حاله نفسيه
مرتبطه بنسبه احاسيس مرتفعه جدا
يستخدم المخدر الموضعي
التمارين اللي بنسميهز لعضلات الحوض
المشكله انه فعاليه هل تقنيتين هي مش كثير
عاليه هلا حسن الحظ صار في دواء ودواء هو
افدي ابروف بينعطها بالفم قبل ساعه او
ساعه ونصف من موعد العلاقه والفعاليه
تبعيته هي مرتفعه جدا هلا طبعا وقت بيصير
هالامور ما تكون فعاله فينا نلجا لامور
حديثه وحديثي جدا من ضمننا حقن عضلات
الحوض بيماده البوتكس هي نفسها يا اللي
يوحن فيها الوجه كمينا فينا نستخدم بعض
الفيلرس براس العضو الذكري لا تخفيف
الحساسيه في هذه المنطقه والاثنين نيته عم
يفرجوا فعليه كثير مرتفعه بالنسبه للقذف
المبكر
[موسيقى]